one of the reasons why the program is so
effective is because of the social
interaction in the groups the groups
create this sense of social support and
friendship that drives motivation and
behavior change of the patients um and
so i i previously thought that you know
the idea of a group visit was was crazy
and uh we should just stick with
one-on-one visits but but really the
science shows that groups provide this
amazing sense of social support that
provides a lot of benefit to the
participants
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet
laurence gerard chief executive officer
of fruit street health lawrence is the
ceo and founder of fruit street health
which is a telehealth company that
delivers the cdc's diabetes prevention
program via live group video visits on
zoom with registered dietitians he has
raised more than 25 million dollars in
funding for the company via crowdfunding
for more than 500 physician investors
lawrence completed his bachelor's degree
at the harvard extension school and was
recently accepted to the program for
leadership development at harvard
business school
while lawrence was originally planning
to go to medical school he decided to
pursue a career using technology and
entrepreneurship to have a social impact
on public health
lawrence gerard welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
[Music]
good how are you
i'm doing great thank you very very much
for joining me here i'm really excited
to talk to you about the founding story
of of fruit street health as well as the
impact that you're having and you're
working with the cdc's diabetes
prevention program and you've fundraised
more than 25 million dollars but you've
done it in a pretty unique way with more
than 500 physicians and so and we're
gonna have a lot of fun talking about it
and talking about your own personal
journey but what i would really love to
start with is the fact that you wrote
thousands of articles for yahoo in high
school in order to pay for your car and
i have seen a lot of fun facts for this
show this is one of the most fun of all
so tell me a little bit about this
entrepreneurial story
yeah well um you know my dad was always
a copywriter and i had kind of gotten
interested in in writing in in eighth
grade and uh just needed needed a way to
pay for my car uh to to go to soccer and
and uh basically um just learned about
these websites like um associated
content and you know demand media and
whatnot and these companies would pay
you at two dollars five dollars ten
dollars an article to write these 400
word articles about
really random things you know it could
be about facts about the monarch
butterfly or um i wrote an article about
the rules for the fifa world cup that
ended up getting featured were i got
like a 500 royalty payment um as well
but
i actually had a professional copy
editor when i was in high school and so
i became a very good writer which is an
essential life skill to be able to you
know write well and coherently and get
your writing criticized so so i have
written thousands of articles about very
random topics um and just became a very
good writer in high school as a result
of that
what what are some memorable topics that
you remember that are perhaps the most
non-trivial of all
well i mean certainly when i wrote that
article about the fifa world cup and i
randomly got a you know i think it was
like a 400 payment in my paypal account
i didn't understand why and it was on
the home page of uh yahoo's associated
content a year after i wrote it so
that's probably the most memorable i
also uh certainly there's a bunch of uh
very obscure topics about like uh facts
about the eukaryotic kingdom and uh you
know articles about hotels and random
cities and
um
that they even paid me 50 dollars once
ran an article
how to tie your shoes so it's very uh
every topic under the sun that you could
imagine
well i can only imagine i i don't even
know how to describe in words in a
written language how to tie a shoe so i
think that
definitely an interesting variety and so
tell me lawrence how you got started
with with a fruit street health and what
is the problem sort of that you
attempted to solve and how you are very
creatively finding a way to solve that
problem
yeah well in high school i was always
interested in
diet and exercise because i was actually
pursuing professional soccer in high
school so i had played for the
new york red bulls academy team is a
goalkeeper when i was 18
but at the time i decided that instead
of pursuing soccer i wanted to focus on
something with more of a social impact
and go to medical school and so the year
after i
graduated from high school i started
volunteering at my local emergency room
in the north shore lij system
and while i was doing that i also took a
nutrition epidemiology course with a
harvard school public health professor
and i realized that i was probably the
only person that has ever taken a
nutrition epidemiology course while
working in an emergency room because
they're polar opposites wow um you know
one focus on prevention and one's
treatment and uh you know one day there
was this man that came in that had
passed away barely due to his obesity
and he had a heart attack and i was in
the room when it happened and i just
realized that this was preventable so i
became very interested in lifestyle
modification and public health learning
about physicians like dean ornish who
proved you could reverse heart disease
through diet and lifestyle and then
basically moved to boston and started
this as a summer project um at the
harvard innovation lab on the business
school campus and uh that was when i was
in the bachelor's degree program at the
harvard extension school
and basically i just got interested in
this idea of using technology and
entrepreneurship to have a social impact
in healthcare and had some local
physicians invest in the company which
is where the name fruit street comes
from it's the address of massachusetts
general hospital and you know the rest
is history but um the specific problem
we're solving is that one in three u.s
adults are pre-diabetic which means they
have elevated blood glucose and they
have a high risk for developing type 2
diabetes
and so this program that we have this
diabetes prevention program is designed
to help them lose five to seven percent
of their weight through diet and
lifestyle um to help them avoid
developing type two diabetes and so
that's the the problem that we're
focused on
and and so that that is the problem and
obviously you know the dissemination of
information is probably the most
critical piece here and and then and
explainability and understanding so how
do you actually go about in doing that
in an innovative way
yeah so um
well you know the history of it's
interesting uh 20 years ago medicare had
spent about 175 million dollars on a
clinical trial where they enrolled about
3 000 patients with pre-diabetes into
this program and they compared a
lifestyle modification program to a
pharmaceutical drug metformin and what
they found was that the lifestyle
program was more effective than
metformin in preventing type 2 diabetes
and that research was published in the
new england journal of medicine
and so the lifestyle group had reduced
their risk for type 2 diabetes by 58
and and so most of the diabetes
prevention programs around the country
are in-person programs at churches
hospitals and ymcas the way we deliver
it is online through telehealth and a
live group video conferencing on zoom
with registered dietitians and so if you
can imagine one dietitian and 30
patients video conferencing on zoom from
either their computer or the food street
mobile app that's how we deliver the
program and then we also issue them a
wireless scale and a fitbit so they can
track their weight loss and physical
activity
and they can also take pictures of their
food in our mobile app and get feedback
from the dietitian
so that's the product and today we sell
it to large self-insured employers and
health plans
but we're also rolling it out as a
direct-to-consumer product as well and
physicians will soon be able to refer
patients to the program as well and so
there's a variety of ways to kind of
educate the public and enroll them into
the into the program
so take me back to the decision to
to get the funding from hundreds of
physicians instead of the traditional
you know venture capital model or
venture debt model why why go through
this route
yeah i think that in healthcare it's
difficult to be exclusively focused on
profit
and you have to have a hybrid approach
of wanting to have a social impact and
have a sustainable business model and i
think often private equity is
exclusively focused on the financial
returns rather than the mindset of a
doctor which is more focused on a
combination of having a social impact
and having a sustainable business model
and so we had made this conscious
decision that we wanted this to be more
of a
grassroots effort of physicians and
individuals who wanted to have a social
impact in health care
and there's a lot of benefits of this um
so we we do have 500 physicians as
investors but they also participate in
an advisory board through software
called basecamp where they give their
feedback and input into different things
like the software design the business
model clinical guidelines um they'll
introduce us to colleagues who might be
interested in referring patients they'll
also introduce us to potential customers
um as well because we're kind of like
crowdfunding the capital for the company
but also crowdsourcing knowledge for the
company and then building a network
right of evangelist who can promote the
company i saw a quote from the ceo of
angel list recently i think it was that
angel investors and venture capitalists
provide um expertise but um crowdfunding
creates fans and customers
i thought that was an interesting one
i i love it okay and and what have you
learned from the from the enablement of
getting these you know these programs
and these educational programs and the
monitoring and the whole the whole
shebang
online so you know obviously you know
it's a very different experience than
getting it in person you're doing it at
scale what have you learned about
disease about diabetes prevention and
education
through
through fruit street health
yeah i think that um the pandemic has
helped everyone to realize that
telehealth is here to stay and that it's
very convenient and
easy to use there was a lot of people
that were skeptical previously but
really the pandemic has caused this
monumental shift in um
telehealth adoption um and that we've
realized that um you know doing a group
video visit on zoom it can be very
similar to the experience you'd have um
in person i think one of the most
surprising things for me was that
one of the reasons why the program is so
effective is because of the social
interaction in the groups the groups
create this sense of social support and
friendship that drives motivation and
behavior change of the patients um and
so i i previously thought that you know
the idea of a group visit was was crazy
and we should just stick with one-on-one
visits but but really the science shows
that groups provide this amazing sense
of social support that provides a lot of
benefit to the participants
right that makes a lot of sense and so
if you were
to look at taking this exam this example
and extrapolate from the model that
you've built and the lessons that you've
learned where else do you think we can
apply a similar tactic to improve the
lives of many people at scale
yeah there's actually many chronic
disease management programs that use
groups in person that are evidence-based
programs that are highly effective
for example there are smoking cessation
programs there's well-known programs
like alcohols anonymous this program's
for patients that already have type 2
diabetes and so we're considering in the
future taking this
software infrastructure we've built for
group visits and applying it to other
diseases to bring these these programs
online through zoom which we've all
become so accustomed to during the
pandemic and so i think that groups
could almost be applied to any
chronic disease
because again it provides a sense of
social support you're going through a
program with other patients that are
experiencing the same thing as you and
that's very powerful
right i think that makes a lot of sense
and if you're looking at your own
journey and you know not from more more
from a leadership perspective
what is it like running a company that
is funded by so many people that is
impacting so many people where where
where do you find yourself
in the midst of all this inter
interaction where you know what what is
your sort of your role your
responsibility your whose commitment are
you going towards
yeah
well my bad joke would be that my job is
fundraising and hiring smart people
because at this stage if you're doing
everything yourself as the ceo you are
guaranteed to fail um and so i really
think it's about you know building a
team of people that can execute and
removing yourself from the business in
many ways
um and uh there was a analogy i heard
recently i forgot who it was exactly i
think it was um the zappos ceo where he
had said that um
you know the ceo of job is like being
like a gardener uh in in a greenhouse
where you're just supposed to be like
watering the plants right and the
employees of the plants rather than this
like super top-down approach so i think
um at an early stage company like this
you have to build the team and then kind
of you know put out fires but also just
like nurture
everything that's going on and make sure
that you're pointing the ship in the
right direction but you can't do all the
work yourself at this stage
right that makes a lot of sense and what
excites you most about you know this
work is it
the being the ceo and and running this
mothership is it the fundraising is it
the the problem that you're solving
uh it's a social impact really i mean
every week we have something that
happens uh where the dietitians on the
front line that teach the program will
share something called the wednesday
wins and those share success stories
from people that have gone through the
program
so sometimes we'll hear about somebody
that has lost 60 pounds and they've been
able to stop taking their diabetes
medication or we'll hear about people
that um
improve their cholesterol or they you
know never thought that they would
achieve this amount of weight loss and
so
ultimately that's why we started the
company you know i was working in an
emergency room and i saw all these
obese patients coming in with
preventable death really
and i wanted to do something about it
and
now we we have where we have people that
you know they may have ended up in the
emergency room if they had not gone
through this program or they may have
developed diabetes or blindness or
amputation um if they didn't go through
this program and so it's rewarding to
see that you know ibm and african become
a reality
now did you was this something that you
planned for for a long time is this
something that you always had within you
that you knew that you wanted to build a
company and a sustainable model
that is going to have a social impact or
is this something that transition
because you mentioned also you know
before we started this that you actually
weren't wanted to be you know go into
medicine and be a doctor right
yeah so in undergrad for the first year
or so i was exclusively focused on going
to medical school
and um you know i was participating in
research i was volunteering in the
emergency room and so forth but the
first year that i was in boston was when
harvard opened the harvard innovation
lab and that was my first exposure to
entrepreneurship um you know every
harvard student has also watched the
social network and so you get exposed to
entrepreneurship that way as well
and i just started to become fascinated
with entrepreneurship and also joined an
organization called
the cairo society which is a student-led
entrepreneurial organization of really
student entrepreneurs that want to you
know improve the world and i just
realized that you didn't have to become
a doctor to help people that you can
almost help more people through
technology and entrepreneurship and so
um
you know that was really thanks to the
harvard innovation lab uh where i just
realized that you could really have a
large-scale social impact through
business and so
i'm not a doctor but you know a lot of
the doctors that we work with say that
you know we're having a larger scale
social impact with this product than if
i would have you know gone to medical
school i mean imagine if we enrolled one
million patients into this program we
would have prevented hundreds of
thousands of cases of diabetes and other
preventable lifestyle related diseases
so i guess uh since college i've wanted
to do something that has had a social
impact
very very cool now
if i were to ask you what inspires you
today and not just the problem that
you're solving which is obviously very
inspirational
where do you find inspiration in your
day-to-day work
yeah i think that it becomes difficult
to stay inspired sometimes when you're
at this stage of a company because often
it becomes a lot about um finance
and spreadsheets and you know raising
capital i mean sometimes i feel like i'm
an investment banker rather than
somebody uh who has come up with a good
product idea and so it can get very um
you know financed griffin um but i think
at the end of the day it's really about
hearing those frontline stories and
connecting the work that i'm doing with
those frontline stories because this
project is not just about money it's
about where the rubber meets the road
right it's you know a patient with a
dietitian that achieves an improvement
in their health and so i think that
sometimes it can get difficult to stay
focused on that but hearing those front
line stories i think can help keep
people motivated they're in the back
office if you will of um you know
finance or accounting and so forth but
you really have to tie it back to the
actual impact that the company is having
as a whole
and how do you then translate this these
frontline stories in this impact to the
people working in the company so because
obviously not every person can just go
and talk to customers that are
working through their own issues right
so how do you then go and leverage this
as an inspiration for the employees of
of your company
yeah right now we're mostly a remote
company that works on slack and basecamp
and really we've made it into this
routine where every week the dietitians
will
publish on every every wednesday every
single wednesday they will publish a
list of basically patient testimonials
and success stories they'll typically be
about 10
every week but we've made it really a
routine where every wednesday we can
look forward to hearing about this and
if you don't make it a routine it just
becomes a bit random but it's it's every
wednesday um without fail they post it
to the company in a slack channel
very very cool and if i were to ask you
for
two or three words that you would use to
describe yourself
what would they be
um i would say resilient
um
i would say uh determination and
entrepreneurial
brazilian determination entrepreneurial
lawrence thank you very very much i
appreciate your time i appreciate your
work thank you for the positive impact
that you're making
i think that when i think through you
know this past this past year and a half
two years and the the companies that
covet enabled to to bring and to give
room to uh you know probably two years
ago people would say well let's replace
in-person groups with zoom groups and
they would be like no way it's not the
same experience and today we we proved
that it's it's a scalable model that can
have just as big as impact and on many
many more people and so i think that i
love what you're doing the approach of
bringing in 500 physicians as investors
and this idea of creating fans and
customers along with investors
i think that's just a that's just really
really great and thank you for the
inspiration thank you for your time
[Music]